thanks for joining us here in delhara as
we approach the start of the World Cup
as we look around Doha the building work
the final touches are being put to Qatar
is the country ready to host this first
Middle East World Cup yes we're ready
Qatar is ready we've been planning for
this for 12 years now so final touches
obviously with any mega event like this
or any event actually that you put in
place there's always the last minute
rush but on a whole in general we're
ready
when you bid it was a time of a global
financial crisis here we are approaching
the World Cup and there's yet more
Global Financial terminal are you
concerned that might be an issue fans
might have to put off their trips it
might be just too costly at the moment
this cost of living crisis globally
I wouldn't say so I mean look I
understand what you're saying yes prices
are being inflated and interest is
inflated but if we look at the ticket
sales we look at the last minute ticket
sales we see the real the uptake on on
the applications of hey Accords the
booking of accommodation it doesn't
indicate that we're going to have any
slowdown on people attending the World
Cup
a lot of issues to get through around
this world cup in particular
particularly England Wales folk is in
recent weeks we've had Venus and Welsh
fa announcing that they're going to wear
one love armbands we're going to have
England Captain Harry Kane Wales Captain
Gareth Bale both wearing one Lavan land
are you fine with Gareth Bale and Harry
Kane wearing those rainbow colored woman
well I don't know because from what I
understand is that there is there is
discussions taking place about the
different political messages
um that are going to be um
but you know there's a lot of political
messages out there right now there's a
lot of things that we read in the Press
about armbands that are going to be warm
we don't know anything that's confirmed
or anything that's official
um but I know that there are discussions
taking place right now I mean obviously
that has been one of the big things in
the build up to this tournament where
the rainbow Flags will be allowed
there has been some confusion could you
clear that up can fans come with Rainbow
Flight
look we've always said that everybody's
welcome here all we ask is for people to
be respectful of the culture we ask for
people to understand that you know
different cultures are are different
people and at the end of the day as long
as you don't do anything that harms
other people if you're not destroying
public property as long as you're
behaving in a way that's not harmful
then everybody's welcome and you have
nothing to worry about
obviously people are trying to get used
to those laws the English FAA chief
executive did say that gay fans have
been put off and coming here to the
World Cup because of the anti-lgbtq laws
what would your message to those fans be
who are sort of where you've made in
front of those lgbtq plus fans no I
don't know anything about what the chief
executive has said about this but I
assure everybody that they're everybody
is welcome here and everybody will feel
safe when they come to Qatar
would that be okay yes
that's a message of reassurance to them
yes
so they could show some form of if I
held your hand Rob right now and I
walked outside the street for hours and
hours and hours nobody would say
anything to us how did you look at some
of the footballers who do raise issues
with Qatar well perhaps you might go on
holiday to Dubai without raising
questions
I mean look you're asking the question
I'm not going to I'm not going to get
into that but I think people should
understand that this is a festival this
is a celebration of football this is a
this is a sporting tournament that
people want to come and enjoy turning it
into this platform of of of of of
political movements and a platform of
political statements I don't think is
right for the sport and I don't think
this is the whole intention of hosting
the World Cup here in Qatar so I think
we need to focus on the sport I think we
need to focus on the preparations of the
World Cup and I think we need to focus
on all the fans need to be focusing on
how well their teams are going to play
and honestly I think teams fans that are
going to keep going to be coming here
should focus on on their booking and
making sure you know they book where
they're going to go eat where they're
going to go for entertainment and really
focus on coming and enjoying themselves
here at a World Cup
um there's other places for for these
political uh discussions
yeah I think a lot of it has to do with
that I think a lot of it is got to do
with
um you know escatar worthy of hosting a
World Cup will Qatar ever be ready to
host the World Cup and you know we've
taken the challenge upon ourselves and
we've risen to that challenge and you
know there's there's you know it's
around the corner here so
um you know that's what we're focusing
on and I'm sure people are going to
enjoy the World Cup here they're going
to enjoy their time in Qatar they're
going to enjoy their time in the region
because I know that there's a lot of
fans that will probably want to visit
more than one country while they're here
and they'll see what the region is
really about and they'll see what Qatar
is about and how amazing this world cup
is going to be
do you feel some like Christmas might
evade into racism
I'm not going to get into uh
um what the intentions are of other
people I'm not going to get into the
minds and Souls of of other people but
you know who knows possibly
one of the other things
in a statement recently was about this
worker compensation from
more assurances and it seems to be
focused more on the wider Qatar projects
rather than necessarily the
World Cup stages themselves have you
responded things you have a message for
the English and Welsh FAS and the other
European FAS who are concerned about the
implementation of this worker
compensation fund look I find a lot of
people that speak about this issue and
work as well further speak about the
issue of workers rights and speak about
this issue as a whole are not experts in
the industry and they're not experts in
what they're speaking about and I feel
that they feel obliged that they need to
speak and I feel that they might think
that they're doing it and they they come
out as as people who are taking a a
stance a moral stance on a specific
subject I think they need to really read
and educate themselves a little bit more
about what's happening on the ground in
Qatar that they need to be
um
understand what's happened over the past
10 or 12 years in terms of Qatar
putting the effort into
changing legislation
progressing rights progressing working
standards introduction of of
minimum wage these are just to name a
few because I've lost count and I don't
understand how how
people don't understand the amount of
work that's gone over the gone in over
the past 10 years in terms of really
really overhauling
um the workers rights and the workers
laws in this country so when people come
out and say yes we know we agree that
there needs to be some sort of
compensation fund so they're just taking
they're just you know reading off a
piece of paper so let's leave that to
The Experts Qatar is working with the
ILO Qatar is working with other ngos on
working on on improving this they've
seen the work that Qatar has done
they've felt the work that that's gone
into this and let's leave them and let
them work and you know let us focus on
football let let the football
administrators focus on their teams and
you know let's just leave it at that
unreasonable that they are bringing this
up with just a few years ago I think
listen I think everybody needs to focus
on their area of expertise right now and
mine is to make sure that you know
working hand in hand with the different
authorities in Qatar working with FIFA
working with all the different
stakeholders to make sure that this is a
successful World Cup make sure that this
is a World Cup that the fans will never
forget and let the the fa administrators
focus on their teams you know and let
the ngos and the ilos of this world and
and the labor authorities of the of this
world focus on their work a lot of folks
have been on the Alcohol policies did
you feel a bit pressured into relaxing
things to sort of sell out no look rob
you know more than anybody else and I've
been saying this to you you know we've
met many times and I've told you that
you know alcohol is available in Qatar
it's more limited than than maybe other
countries in the world whether it's in
in Europe or the us or or or other
countries in Eastern Europe in in in in
in the east
but it will be more available in
designated zones in Qatar and here we
are today we have it in designated zones
like we've promised from from day one
we've heard about the drunk tanks that
are going to be there to help maybe fans
sober up a bit could you explain how
they will work well you know I mean I
don't I don't know where you heard about
it I know that there are plans in place
for people to sober up if you know if
they've you know if they've been
drinking excessively
um it's a place to make sure that
there's you know they keep themselves
safe they're not harmful to anybody else
they don't get themselves harmed and I
mean I think it's a good idea
we're coming to the end of a year that's
seen
a war launched by Russia and Ukraine so
much disharmony so much Strife you are
bringing football fans to the Middle
East for the first time to a World Cup
in a Muslim Nation for the first time
what can message from that send out what
are you hoping to achieve with this
world cup in a Muslim Nation for the
first time in the Middle East for the
first time
we you know football brings people
together every four years we see this
and in the World Cup we see this
everyone's glued to their TV everybody's
talking about football about this team
or that team or this goal or that goal
yes this is a special World Cup it's
happening in the Middle East for the
first time be it's happening in the
winter season for the first time as well
um I believe it's going to be a special
World Cup because of the amount of
um
I think the amount of attention that's
been given to this world cup from 2009
2010 when Qatar won the bid I think the
amount of work that's gone into it by
by
the country
the transformation that we've seen over
the past 10 years I think we're you know
um it's going to be a message of
Celebration it's going to be a message
of people coming together and look Rob
I'm pretty sure there's a lot of people
that are going to come here and say we
expected this it's not we expected this
to be a great world cup and we you know
they've either visited the region or
they're not under some really bad
preconception of of the region but yes
there was there will also be the people
that are going to come here for the
first time are going to and gonna Wonder
I didn't know what to expect but but you
know looking at this this is quite
amazing and this place is is is
beautiful and I can't believe that you
know I could have missed such an
experience or I couldn't believe that I
was not actually thinking of not coming
but
you know it's it's it it's at the end
it's going to be a place where people
are going to be having fun getting to
meet new people and people are going to
remember that you know this first Middle
Eastern World Cup was
was something amazing